there was a party mood on the eve of the
North American auto show as
mercedes-benz unveiled its sculpted new
SUV the G le coupe Mercedes has declared
2015 the year of the SUV and plans to
expand its business in the American
market yeah here we have four new SUVs
launching this year there's a high
demand for utility vehicles so the
timing couldn't be better business is
also booming at Volkswagen last year the
company broke a new sales barrier
selling 10 million vehicles worldwide
the firm also plans to bring more SUVs
onto the American market interconnected
vehicles are one trend set to
revolutionize the roads in the coming
years and BMW shares in the vision I
think what we're seeing at the moment is
connectivity is really taking a big step
forward so now whether it be technology
which is going to use the connectivity
of the car around other cars or whether
it is going to be those that connect to
other people's business life or private
life or music environment I think this
is really now at a point where in the
next two to three years we're going to
see an explosion of opportunity
automotive history was written in
Detroit by Henry Ford and a new
generation of automakers are looking to
recreate the magic of Motor City
most car manufacturers are upbeat about
the future right now especially here in
the US the economy is growing fast
Americans are spending and few prices
are falling that of course means that
people are getting less worried about
fuel efficiency and turning again to
trucks SUVs and sports cars